this is a fascinating article making the
rounds on the internet recently about
how the Instagram generation now
experiences the present as an
anticipated memory you know the success
of photo filtering apps on social media
has created a generation of individuals
who now believe that every present
moment needs to be experienced as
something that will be reflected upon
later and we take it upon ourselves to
design what that later moment is going
to feel like we're living in two
realities at the same time it's what
Daniel Kahneman used to refer to as the
experiencing self and the remembering
self and they're working in concert
they're saying be happy for this moment
for this moment is your life but guess
what this moment is going to be gone
like this and all you're gonna have left
is that photo filter vintage photograph
all you're going to have left is how you
choose to remember this moment so you're
given a pen you're given a chance to
decide how this moment will be
remembered and I think that is
fascinating we all became artists we all
become architects of our mental
narratives of our historical digital
paper trail we decide who we are we're
building maps and those maps are
subjective I don't think it's a bad
I do think is fascinating I think it
liberates our desire to be artists our
desire to be the authors of our lives
inside how we remember things to decide
how we deal with the fact that every
moment passes how we deal with that
tragedy how we'll deal with that entropy
you know at least we're going to
italicize the memory of it and so yes
the president has lived as anticipated
memory because that's all we have is the
anticipated memory presents gone it's
rich but it's gone
net you know haunts me but we deal with
it
you